feel good to have you back how are you
this morning
Danielle good to be with you buddy um
favorite story in the book uh well
that's a funny ones you know I mean just
goofball stuff you know doing it you
know I did this for the kid my kid my
kids were all born after I was finished
playing and so they didn't have any
connection and so my ten-year-old I
think came home one day about five or
six years ago and said hey Dad someone
told me at school that you and you know
I don't know I'm like Joe Montana tried
to poison you I mean oh my gosh I got it
and I didn't keep a diary oh there's no
there's no no history and I was like I
got it do something so the kids know
something that they could read and so
that's what got me started and that was
an intent of it and I expected to get a
box full of stuff because I had Jeff
Bennett if you had written and I friend
you know in front of a friend so I had
him get started on it just to put an era
together together for the kids and so
what was fun about doing it is the
stories that rolled in from all my
teammates and people that I've been
around and I forgotten like if I would
have written down myself
I would I would have not remembered
write it right in the 49er helmet around
Rocklin training camp you know that your
little golf cart helmet you know yeah we
stole it went out the Dairy Queen and we
had a parade like literally went through
the drive-thru and then you know then
down the Main Street and people were we
was like it was like a parade no down
the so we just had lots of fun crazy
stuff and I you know I really was more
than anything getting done with it and
and realizing jeez
a lot of stuff happened and I know I can
hand it to the kids and that's kind of
what I wanted to do and then they said
well you know you got some chapters here
won't let people read them they say oh
no that's great you should publish it
and like no no no no but here we are so
I guess we're gonna let it rip but the
favorite stories I don't I I love you
when you went to Montana's house for
dinner
maybe that's where your kids thought
that Montana tried to poison you
he did it I made it up I didn't my son
did not say okay I heard I couldn't
remember the original he said they got
me started on this but I've been
facetious I just joke like you know but
that's the kind of crap of you-you-you
that if you know if you don't kind of
tell your story that people kind of
perpetuate like this goofball stuff
that's not true and then you don't and
no one knows what really happened and
the truth is Joe and I I mean I always
said it so it was awkward but we went as
well as it could ever go and we never
had an argument we never had a cross
word we you know I mean to the extent we
could support each other was not an easy
thing go Walsh was jammed us together
and off we went so that's part of us you
know a lot of it's that four or five
years little six seven years together
which people didn't realize when I was
playing he was still on the team but you
go liver for dinner and is this
Thanksgiving you know it's but I was the
other part of it it's like yeah I can
remember Thanksgivings it was a holiday
time and then as it was maybe his
daughter she had two or three verse four
years old maybe not even and it's just
that is this the guy we're supposed to
hate that one what was the toughest
toughest story to tell uh probably about
you know I grew up people know I mean I
grew up not knowing that I had
separation anxiety I kind of you know
this this kind of genetic thing that now
that now that I'm on the other side of
it and I see it's running through my
mom's family like up and down you know
sprinkled in and out even my son a
little bit so I grew up kind of severely
not able to go any I couldn't leave home
like I had a tough time going to second
grade I mean I had a brutal time going
to college but then you know then that
the rigor of going through that and
walking through it was really the
toughest part of my story that knowing
you know what am I gonna say hey guys
I'm really homesick I don't want to go
back from you know I didn't unpack my
bags in college for through the first
semester because I was struggling well
you don't really I didn't know until I
was mid-30s that this was you know
something you're born with it's not like
you know for me the games were in life
and death you know and then John
Taylor's over laughing and telling jokes
and I'm like come I can't be like John
Taylor and laugh and tell jokes right
before the game you know like it's part
of your genetics kind of weird he's
Steve Young the Hall of Fame of the book
is my life being hind the spiral now
available wherever books are sold you
know and you go to BYU if I give you a
mulligan coming out of BYU what would
you done I really I I mean it was the
Cincinnati Bengals they had the first
pick and you know Kenny Anderson was
there and I could have done done that I
know that's interesting you say that cuz
Dan I went to the USFL first of all
because Sid Gillman was a coach and a
lot more comfort around being in LA and
know a lot of more people and I felt
like Don classmen didn't sold me as an
ex Los Angeles Rams he ran the Rams for
many years it was just really for the
USFL it was a you know some great new
Zimmerman was on the team and future
hall-of-famer there's a lot of great
young players so for me doing that and
then if it didn't go well I'd be a free
agent was the theory where it got really
messed up was when the Players
Association kind of sold out those
policy stole cuz it was me on the other
side to the to the plate to the till
League and allowed a supplemental draft
and that's when I was drafted to the
Tampa you know Tampa Bay had the first
pick and took me so that's where it went
haywire because the plan was go play
with these young players
it was great football the truth was the
football was better in LA than it was in
Tampa Bay and so that experience I would
if you give me a mulligan I would do the
same experience I just probably would
have had more wide-open eyes that I
probably wasn't going to come back into
the NFL if that happened as a free agent
that was the that was the theory that
that got it done
why was everybody trying to set you up
on a date couldn't you do things on your
own how could you be struggling oh your
is not a problem I'm just saying people
because someone tried to set you up
doesn't mean you have a problem well you
make you're making assumption see that's
why we're
I have to kind of solve these
misconception but weren't they trying to
fix you up with Marie Osmond well my I
one of the families that I kind of when
I landed at BYU is the family is part of
the book that I kind of was attracted to
just be there you know just the noise of
the world of the house made me feel much
more comfortable but next door was the
Osmond
ironically and so we did go on a date
and Marie and I are friends we've been
raising money for children Miracle
Network for 30 years I've been trying to
help where I can but we went on one date
and realized we probably better friends
would you rather have joe Montana's
career or tom brady's and you have to
pick oh geez
pretty good um well I mean it's not even
over yet I mean Dan I mean I guess Tom
Bray I mean he's gonna continue my play
three or four more years can he be
better than Phil can we recognize him is
better than Joe no you don't want to I
mean honestly
Joe did things that you just you just
can't imagine and Tom would say the same
thing but Tom at the end has done is so
extended on the game he has taken what
the great did and and just extended
vessel Peyton did too they looked at
everything that everyone before them had
done and then they extended on it and
they took football further so that's why
I hate comparisons because they clearly
build off each other and so it's like
you can't they're not one-to-one it's
like you know I every I came on and
wanted to build off of Roger Staubach
and what he did and then you know it's
like guys you want to extend the game
and so to me the comparisons are brutal
I know you love it but I kind of look
back and appreciate because they're so
rare great quarterbacks are so rare that
when they do show up I tend not to try
to like oh I want to put one on top of
the other one but those two you don't
want those two don't deserve to be put
on top of one other just enjoy just
appreciating those the different errors
but appreciate both of them final minute
here you look at the Cowboys situation I
remember you used to not happen you
wouldn't lose your job if you were
injured is that still the case and you
look at that Dallas situation is this
still Tony Romo's
when he comes back well I thought so for
sure until yesterday no I mean it I mean
it's like all of a sudden the team says
to themselves we're going on the road
and we're taking people down and we're
taking down the big team in the big boys
when you start doing that and you don't
because you got an inevitably feel like
there's some lucky games coming from dak
but now he did that yesterday is like
well maybe he needs to just stay on the
field and you know when he falters Tony
can come in but the problem with that is
that you don't want to take a young
quarterback and bench him when he has
one couple bad games because you got
this phenomenal football player behind
him I tend to want you know didn't
really basically would hurt me back in
the day but the veteran to be the guy
that's you know carrying of water and if
he can't get it done the young guy can
come in it's feels like it the locker
room would respond better to that but
after yesterday I think it's a little
bit more muddled to be honest with you
yeah I agree that locker room is a
tricky tricky dynamic the book is
quarterback my life behind the spiral
very candid but you've come to expect
that from Steve Young good luck with the
book and you know how many kids do we
have now poor okay whenever I hear the
title the kids did but you know my mom
and my wife and every we did the cover
and you know sort of within the title
and you know it was a family thing was
fun it was fun
remember when you said that I didn't
give you a heads-up on what married life
was all about after you had your first
child like you blamed me for some reason
like you didn't tell me about this I'm
like but I did become a pro very quickly
I could go into the restaurant where
they don't have to in the men's room
they don't have the changing table by
the way so you kind of do the
wall-to-wall sit diaper bag next to you
the baby in your lap that you've just
formed out of the wall set and I could
change a diaper on my own lap I mean I
remember one guy was walking out one day
and the bathrooms like hate kept looking
at me and goes hey are you are you Steve
Young I was like I finished my little
yes I am like I just whipped it out it
was perfect
good to hear from you Steve good luck
with the book Dan thanks buddy all right
that's Steve Young the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience